[Applause]
Joe it's kind of interesting it's it's
like they're all about managing risk but
not managing criminals are you surprised
not at all the way they're saying things
like when you go out don't wear jewelry
don't um don't make eye contact with
people if you're telling people that
congratulations you've already made them
a victim okay and if you're gonna tell
me I don't want to live in a world where
I can't hold uncomfortable eye contact
with strangers
but I think what it shows is that they
have to feel the pain before they'll
make the changes okay we had an assembly
woman in New York who moved out of
Harlem complaining about the crime when
she said let's defund the police and
this is what it takes we had another
politician in Minnesota who she was a
huge Lefty socialist Democratic let's
defund the police vicious about it and
then she got carjacked and beat up in
front of her house and now oh she's
putting the fun and refund the police
yeah she's she's ready to have a bake
sale in front of her house so yeah it
just goes to show you it's got to hit
them the way that it hits regular people
before they'll do anything about it that
is so true yeah you know these little
tips it's like telling a girl if you
don't want to get raped don't wear a
short skirt yeah yeah I wore a short
skirt today just to make that point
for a recommendation right Greg like
don't play ping pong politics with
Public Safety right you defund the
police and then you refund the police
San Francisco votes in a cell phone
crime D.A and then they outvote him and
then DC amends the crime Bill to be soft
on crime then they outboard that crime
but like can we stop having Public
Safety as a social experiment yeah it's
true yeah by the way oh
and Cat I like to take this opportunity
to announce that I'm running for
district attorney
you're gonna go from lawyer to a
comedian to lawyer again that's right a
lawyer sandwich cat you know uh we are
paying these people for the we're paying
for their security their drivers they
don't have to risk daily criminal
obstacle courses like everybody else
does what do you say well what's
interesting is if you kind of summarize
all of their advice it is go into every
single situation thinking about how
something catastrophic might happen
which when they do it it's a safety
meeting but when I do it it's anxiety
disorder right
I actually have received professional
help to try to stop thinking this way
and now apparently this is what I'm
supposed to be doing according to the
government yeah that's that's no way to
live no it's okay when you pull up and
do a parking spot make sure that you
have enough room to run away in case
someone attacks you like like no I'm all
like I'm no you know it's funny it's
like the advice parents gave their kids
you know don't talk to strangers don't
take any candy
it's insane while you're driving just
lay on the horn the whole time how
scared you are exactly Tyrus in a way
though it's like DC just keeps
reelecting
the same pro-criminal people hey it's
Will Kane click here to subscribe to the
Fox News Channel on YouTube it's the
best way to get our latest interviews
and highlights and click to subscribe to
the will Kane podcast for full episodes
right now